en choisissant de frapper l'irak est de
briser la chine de l'irak qui était un
état laïc
à ce moment là on ouvrez toutes grandes
les voies à à l'extrémisme religieux au
fanatisme à ce qu'on a appelé ensuite le
djihadisme de al qaida et de dèche
al qaïda est sorti de cet épisode c'est
parce que le l'arabie saoudite a eu
recours à l'armée américaine que oussama
ben laden a jeté al qaïda contre les
états unis
l'épisode d'aider des tours jumelles
reste présent à votre esprit et ensuite
la destruction de l'irak a offert un
boulevard au djihadisme
ça a été d'abord un épisode à al qaïda
dont le chef était al zarkaoui dans les
provinces occidentales de l'irak celles
qui étaient traditionnellement sunnite
et puis ensuite ça a été des ch 1 il
faut bien voir que l'irak est un pays
composite a payé difficile rares étaient
les hommes politiques en occident qu'il
connaissait j'en étais est le seul autre
que j'ai trouvé c'est jacques chirac en
2003 d'ailleurs en 2003 jacques chirac a
brandit son veto à l'idée d'une invasion
de l'irak est et il a bien fait de ne
pas aussi à la france à ce qui se révèle
être un malheur parce que ce que nous
avons vécu depuis
si on veut bien le comprendre n'est que
la suite de cette histoire là 1le le
développement de l'islamisme radical
le djihadisme les attentats tout cela
c'est un peu la conséquence du mauvais
traitement de ce qui était un problème
au départ parce que je ne dis pas qu'il
n'ya pas des causes endogènes à
l'islamisme bien sûr que si comme eni en
était une
et puis l'islamisme des racines
historiques le wahhabisme on arabie
séoudite les frères musulmans en egypte
et en syrie
donc il y à un des facteurs endogènes
mais il ya aussi des facteurs exogènes
dire que l'occident a très mal traiter
ce problème et ça lui est revenue
malheureusement sur la figure
c'est ce à quoi nous assistons
aujourd'hui
[Musique]